in the last few minutes the new draft
agreement has just dropped we've had
this from
the cop president alok sharma
he has said that well he said this
document shows us that the language
mentioning fossil fuels has changed but
fossil fuel subsidies is still mentioned
within the agreement if i just read it
out to you this is quite significant
because let's remember we've been
talking today about countries like saudi
arabia like russia like china thinking
that initially it was mentioned in the
draft agreement but could it well be
phased out of the next version of the
agreement this is what it says this is
paragraph 20. now it calls upon the
party so all 197 parties who are here at
cop 26 to accelerate the development
deployment and dissemination of
technologies like green energy
technologies and the adoption of
policies to transition to low emission
energy systems including by rapidly
scaling up clean power generation and
this is the crucial bit accelerating the
phase out of unabated coal power and of
inefficient subsidies of fossil fuels
why is this significant well this is
significant because for the first time
this is the first time the united
nations deal any form of united nations
deal has mentioned the term coal or the
term fossil fuel subsidies that's what
we've all been waiting for across
past cops past conference of parties
it's often the case that when these
draft agreements are drawn up often the
um language changes over time and often
the draft agreement is very different to
the final thing so the fact that the um
the fact that this
this most recent document that we're
waiting all hours or waiting for it it
is now here